cette œuvre de ester Waro s'intitule
alors c'est une photographie
de grand format numérique qui a été créé
en 1999
cette oeuvre représente le contact
fusionnel entre deux êtres vivants
un poulpe
adoptant la forme des orteils d'un pied
légèrement cambré
et la force du numérique optimise le jeu
d'ombres et de lumière et fait émerger
d'un aplat bleuâtre une création
mi-humaine et mi animale c'est un gros
plan à la forme étrange qui possède une
force visuelle indéniable
l'animal de couleur rouge sont semblant
s'agripper et serré la partie supérieure
du pied visiblement crispé évoque à la
fois l'horreur mais aussi montre une
rencontre sensuelle
par cette œuvre esthero nous révèle son
travail d'exploration
personnelle et évoque ainsi la question
amoureuse dans le rapport à soi-même et
le rapport à l'autre
cette image du corps humain qui se mêle
à d'autres figures est une invitation au
monde onirique et aussi au domaine de la
fiction alors c'est l'oeuvre que lui a
inspiré le Japon où elle a vécu quelques
mois le signe d'une première exploration
hors de son corps et la rencontre de ses
orteils avec des drôles de sensations
animales
l'artiste se découvre elle-même dans la
matière mais le travail évoluera vers
des propositions plus aériennes
à travers ces photographies et star
warro fait hommage au cinéaste
britannique Alfred Joseph Hitchcock
début du 20e siècle qui s'est spécialisé
dans les films à suspense et thriller